dann auch nacken und dann nahm ich ein
schläfer der hatte löcher drin und ein
klar und ein sommerkleid waren die einst
müssen klatscht wie ich bin immer noch
sehr gute stück ist ein toller tag
die ganze zeit
[Musik]
du bist im april 1944 bist du abgeholt
worden die von zu hause
wie ist es überhaupt dazu gekommen als
achtjähriges kind wurde ich aufgeweckt
in einer in einer nacht im april und
angezogen und mir wurde gesagt junge du
musst jetzt mit dem mann los ziehen
ich hab versucht seine hand zu nehmen um
wusste wo ich trank
andy hat mit mit erwachsenen hand zu
halten
aber der hat meine hand abgelehnt hat
man ahnt abgelehnt wollte man nicht mal
an abend ran anfassen
als ich ankam ich war die letzte die auf
die aus den waggons heraus gegen meinen
kleinen koffer öffnete sich und man die
ganzen sachen viel heraus und ich
drückte mich dann um nie wieder
reinzuholen raten anzustecken und wurde
angeschrieben angeschrieben dass ich
dass ich schneller schnell schnell
schnell und eine sinti frau kam wieder
zurück und sagte zu mir dass das liegen
lass das läge sei auf rennen rennen lass
das liegen
und dann habe ich das alles liegt liegen
gelassen mein koffer mit mit mit der
andern unterwäsche und so weiter und so
fort und rannte ich war ein kind
ich wusste nicht was los war hat sie
erst der kosten aus der dusche kam
unsere sachen die wir alle in einen
haufen draußen auf dem fußboden und alle
heckel die pickel die über und leute
mussten losziehen und sieht sich
ursachen herausfinden um sich wieder
anzuziehen und zu guter letzt als der
ungefähr noch
456 sachen affen fußboden lagen hat eine
frau an es sind die frau bemerkt gehängt
immer dass ich an kind alleine bin und
hat zu mir gesagt du musst irgendwas
nehmen
du hast noch nichts an ich war immer
noch bestand immer noch nacken
du hast du nichts haben die musste ich
etwas anziehen
ich sage ich kam hab gesagt ja ich kann
meine sachen nicht finden neben
irgendwas nehmen was und dann nahm ich
ein schläfer der hatte schon löcher und
drin
ich nehme an dass dass er das war der
grund dass er nicht nicht genommen wurde
an schlüpfer mit löchern
den habe ich genommen habe ich genommen
und ein klar und ein sommerkleid cotton
baumwolle mit kurz kurz kurzem welches
ungefähr passte ungefähr
und das war alles das war alles was ich
hatte da war nichts mehr da war nichts
mehr keine strümpfe keine schuhe nichts
das war die halle die zweite platz war
klar um stücke waren die einst müssen
klar ich bin immer noch sehr gute stück
ist die ganze zeit
dafür war neben tun ich es natürlich
heutzutage bündeln niemand erwartet dass
es jetzt über solche schlachten zu
schlagen ist es trocken schlucken und
gestreut über die schlaglöcher große
schlaglöcher im innerschweizer beliefert
dies kostet so presseamt in moskau so
press
mama ist denn 3d shooter und ordensburg
aber dass magna bei dem du aufgewachsen
ist hatte ich nicht vergessen in der
zeit nein ja dann hat alles getan um zu
sehen was du getan hast zuerst ist es
treten kriminalrätin kann in hamburg
dann hat er angefangen briefe zu
schreiben hat sogar an hitler
geschrieben an göring an alle
und zu guter letzt hat er einen plan
bekommen von martin bormann
das musste so hochgehen ist zu martin
dohmen bevor jemand die die society
hatte um das zu veranlassen dass jemand
aus einem konzentrationslager entlassen
wurde
auf jeden fall mein vater hat das hat
das geschafft und dann musste ich ins
büro musste ich mich dahin setzen wurde
sitzt ich hin
sein vater kommt da mussten im shop ist
was ich wollte
schockierte thoma ich war traumata ist
der ton den cayenne porsche vielleicht
später hat mein vater gesagt sein kind
erschien irgendwie als in abensberg wie
eine mumie
das heißt du deinen eltern und
geschwistern geredet die haben mich
nicht ab auch nachgefragt nur mein vater
hat mich danach gefragt hat mich aber in
einem schlafzimmer genommen um mit mir
alleine zu sprechen und da hat mich
gefragt was
wie die sache da links das ging nach los
und ich habe ihnen gesagt hab aber und
da wurden leute lebendig verbrannt du
bist du bist ja quasi ein mensch der der
der 3 wenn sie täten haben könnte als
das fühlst du dich gut christkind gute
frage
man darf nicht vergessen und das erst in
48 war wurde mir deutsche
staatsangehörigkeit zugesprochen
aber die anti deutsche
staatsangehörigkeit so spät im leben zu
bekommen
man ist sich nicht sicher ist man
richtig deutsch ist man richtig deutsch
ist man richtig 100 prozent ist man isst
man sinti und roma ist man sinti und
roma und sinti und roma zusammengelebt
auf jeden fall bin ich nicht englisch
vielleicht würde ich wenn ich gezwungen
würde würde ich lasse mich bezeichnen
als eine deutsche sinti und roma frau
berndt wurde dass dichter
das war ganz ganz ganz gegen uns
wirklich mehr als last und versprochen
habe vielen dank dafür
okay da war nicht viel fertig